I think that a lot of Boomers have given
up on Free Speech because they feel like
oh things are too important now and they
taught their children I have a two kids
one is a millennial and one is Gen X I
didn't teach them this but they got from
a lot of different places that speech is
the equivalent of action and that words
wounds you know like bullets or knife
blades and this is what happens when you
teach that there's an equation between
speech and action then you have to
police speech because it's the same
thing it's like
who's been teaching this in Washington
speech in action yeah I mean I think
that is a coursing through K through 12
education I think through a lot of media
and and creative work and things like
that